[Music]
here's a question for you should we make
reading aristotle compulsory in school
you're probably going to say no and i'm
going to say no to with the proviso but
I'm going to say no probably for very
different reasons than you are and if
you're one of the people who actually
says yes that's a really great idea I'm
in sympathy with you but I would also
lay down certain demands that would make
it practically not impossible but pretty
difficult for you to realize that so
here's my rant
[Music]
about a week and a half ago I got into
an interesting discussion actually a
little bit of a debate on Twitter and it
was fairly amicable as far as Twitter
goes you know that can be kind of a
cesspool as far as the discussion the
character limits you don't get me
started on all of that because there's a
lot that can be said about that and it
had to do with this question of making
reading of Aristotle compulsory in
schools now it didn't specify whether
we're talking about kindergarten through
twelfth grade or you know college or any
other kinds of schools just schools and
the person who started it off said
compulsory reading of Aristotle in
school would do a lot more good for the
country than any other social experiment
on offer so it's coming from you know
what we can guess to be a fairly you
know traditionalist right-wing
conservative perspective not necessarily
one that is you know just populist or
anything like that because I think
suggesting Aristotle is already the anti
populist if you know your your Aristotle
and I responded by saying this and this
is what kept the discussion going
compulsory reading of Aristotle that
would turn students off for life
Aristotle requires competent teaching
and application to be useful so I'm
making two points there and then one of
my interlocutors not the original poster
but somebody else chimed in and said
these don't seem to be mutually
exclusive than if you look at the
Twitter conversation you can see that I
messed with them a little bit you know
and said well you know teaching and
application aren't really mutually
exclusively said no no what I mean is
making it compulsory and teaching it
applying it competently and I said yeah
you're right they're not mutually
exclusive
whoever claimed that they were as a
matter of fact I would go so far and
here is my position
this to say that if you want to teach
Aristotle in school let alone make
Aristotle compulsory well then you'd
better find some people who are
competent teachers who really know the
stuff and then you have to go beyond
that it's reading is not enough in order
for you to take a moral philosopher
particularly somebody with the
complexity and depth of and richness of
Aristotle's thought it's got to be
application and even real-life
applications to the lives of the
students or it's not going to click it's
not going to matter and if you can't do
that then don't talk about making it
compulsory because all you're doing then
is setting students up to be turned off
and to never read Aristotle in your in
their life so if your goal is actually
get people to read Aristotle or going
beyond that to you know take what's in
his text it's of such great value and
start changing their lives changing
their communities with it
well by god you'd better have some
competent expositors in the classroom
people who really know the text really
know what they're doing it's not enough
to have fans who you know we're told in
some history of philosophy that
Aristotle did this and that and that's a
good thing you need to actually read
your Aristotle understand it and you'd
better know where you disagree with
Aristotle and why you disagree with him
otherwise you can't be a good teacher of
Aristotle so I got a lot to say about
this and I'm going to go through these
points one by one not necessarily in a
logical order but but I think that this
is stuff that could be quite
thought-provoking for many people so let
me say from the start that I'm actually
probably a bigger fan of Aristotle than
most of the people who would find this
this idea of making reading Aristotle
compulsory think themselves to be in
part because I've spent more than half
of my life actually reading Aristotle
reading him in the original at least as
close to it as we can get
you know the critical versions in Greek
of his tag
I've written on Aristotle I presented on
Aristotle
I've given talk after talk after talk
about Aristotle I've applied Aristotle
within the context of executive coaching
life coaching philosophical counseling
so you can guess I'm somebody who really
really is a fan of Aristotle and I'm not
going to be saying oh no no no don't
have students read that stuff without
some good reason to say that so what is
my good reason well Aristotle is pretty
hard when I first read Aristotle I
couldn't make heads or tails of half of
it and the other half I said well this
is just plain common sense or it's
boring that was you know many many years
ago and I didn't actually have competent
teachers to help me through it and I
started out with Aristotle's categories
and Aristotle's Nicomachean ethics but I
had a sort of adverse reaction to
Aristotle as a smart student so imagine
just throwing these books in students
hands and saying go to it Johnny
go to it Susie read some Aristotle let's
talk about it later well that's going to
have almost the opposite reaction of
what you want what what you need is
people who really understand the text to
sit down with students and you know take
manageable portions manageable chunks
and say we're going to work through this
and then you know if you're going to
keep reading it see how the different
texts are interconnected with each other
which sometimes you can't really do and
once you can read Greek or unless you
you know have somebody else who reads
Greek for you show you where these
connections are so I'm you know I'm
probably one of the biggest fans of
Aristotle and I'm going against the
other Aristotle fans who are you might
say you know fans in the in the sense of
just they they really like the stuff
that he's putting out they have an
emotional attachment to it but they
don't really get into it quite quite so
much I would also add to that other
Aristotle scholars are going
be with me on this you know one of the
people who I particularly like both
personally and in terms of his thought
is Alistair McIntyre he's got a great
piece called plain persons and moral
philosophy that I use when I teach
ethics classes and in it he talks about
that you know the ordinary person is
probably a proto Aristotelian which is
why there can be some subtraction and he
says the worst thing we could possibly
do is just throw the nick of McCann
ethics at students and say here read up
on this it's going to really change your
life because they're going to open it up
and say what the hell is this I don't
know what he's talking about here
everything has ends you know virtuous
activity all sorts of side discussions
about you know can the dead be happy
what the hell is this stuff right
MacIntyre recognizes he says we have to
do a lot of interpretation for these
students and it makes total sense we're
not living in the 4th century BC right
these works were written for different
contexts that doesn't mean that they're
not applicable today but we can't do it
in a cookie cutter sort of way we
actually have to do a lot of adaptation
with to do a lot of application we have
to do a lot of getting students to see
that this connects up with and
illuminates their experience and in
order to do that you have to have done
some of that in your own life with the
Aristotle and not in a cookie cutter
schematic way Aristotle's thought is
incredibly flexible the the way in which
many people apply them is not now here
I'm going to go into another digression
you know when we're talking about making
you know reading and study is something
compulsory within the curriculum I think
that you know if you know your history
of ideas and you know anything about
what scholasticism had turned into and
why the early modern philosophers were
reacting against that and why scholastic
became kind of a byword
and you know way to denigrate somebody
you won't be so eager to to do that with
students you know people like Thomas
Hobbs Rene Descartes they read their
Aristotle they had plenty of people who
said well the answers to this problem
are in this text just read it and it'll
all work out and it didn't satisfy them
why not because it was badly taught it
wasn't really well thought out and and
when it came to the places where
Aristotle actually turned out to be
wrong people tried to figure out ways
they could [ __ ] it to make sure that
you know he didn't turn out to be wrong
and you know why would we want to
replicate something like that today I
just can't see that I would love let me
let me preface this by saying I would
love to see every student in our nation
in the United States actually every
student across the world
reading Aristotle's Nicomachean ethics
reading is politics reading the on the
soul reading all sorts of Aristotelian
works the rhetoric to them particularly
fond of and I'd like to see them read it
not just once to get it over with and
take a test on it but to go back to it
over and over and over again but I know
that if we want that to happen we have
to approach it in a very different way
we can't just impose this on students as
if somehow they're just going to respond
to it and the people who we would have
doing the initial exposition and
interpretation and application I don't
think that most of them would be up to
it I mean think about the current crop
of K through 12 teachers or the current
crop of probably philosophy professors
in universities and colleges I wouldn't
as an Aristotle scholar and as somebody
who teaches Aristotle and somebody who
loves Aristotle I wouldn't trust 99% of
them to competently teach Aristotle and
to do so in a way that wouldn't
managed to turn students off 99% I would
say at this point in time may be among
philosophy professors maybe I'd say only
80% would would get that from me but I
know from interacting with them from
presenting papers at conferences to my
peers how few of them actually remember
very much from their their reading of
Aristotle as students now what would be
the prospect we could of course have
some sort of curriculum in training the
trainers in educating the educators but
who would put that into play when we
when we find some big institution to
back that up the way that say you know
gates backed up the the Common Core I
mean if we could that would be great I'd
be happy to spearhead that that
initiative that would be a worthwhile
thing for me to do with my life if
somebody wanted to throw a lot of money
at it I would happily educate educators
in how to you know lead students into
Aristotle but until that's going to
happen what we'd be stuck with are the
run of the mill for the most part with
the occasional person who really is good
at it and cares about Aristotle and
understands Aristotle so you know the
person that I was interacting with is
totally right compulsory reading of
Aristotle competent teaching of
Aristotle they're not mutually exclusive
at all I would go so far as to say you
can't really have one without having the
other so let's put it as an if/then at a
practical if then if you have competent
teaching exposition interpretation
application then it makes sense to make
reading of Aristotle compulsory but if
you don't have that if you don't have
that condition then it would be a
terrible idea to make reading of
Aristotle compulsory it would be
counterproductive it would turn
more students off from Aristotle it
would turn them away from Aristotelian
modes of thinking which are very
powerful which is again I use in my own
practice and with my clients and I teach
to students and I see them successfully
apply in their own life there's a few
other things I want to say about this as
well what's the mindset that thinks that
just by making reading a particular
author compulsory across the board that
we would produce some useful social
change I think that that has happened a
lot on the left but I think this is a
great example of that happening on the
right as well it's not people on the
Left who are saying oh man we got to
make people read Aristotle instead it's
whatever flavor of the month happens to
be for you no it's going to change
people's consciousness by confronting
them with this book it's mostly people
on the right who are saying yeah we got
it people read Aristotle do these really
work out that way there's just merely
throwing material at people change their
their mindset what is the mindset to
think that that works that's that's what
I'd like that to ask right there and
then you know we can think about the
broader context we should make any sort
of reading compulsory or you know if we
really care about students and we really
care about our society and we think that
something is a valuable text and it's
not something that you know immediately
grasp because almost nothing that's
worthwhile is immediately grasped you
know that's in a way a sign of a
mediocre text the fact that anybody can
get it automatically it's probably wrong
too if we're going to make things
compulsory we really owe it to our
students to find people who understand
that stuff that we're doing and if we
have to train them then we have to train
them if they have to train themselves in
order to be competent expositors great
as part of what education is about you
know if you're an educator your
education should be going on for your
life it's not like you get your
sheepskin and now you're ready to teach
you need to be doing continual education
and you should be more passionate about
the things that you're teaching then
your your beginning level students who
are getting into it for the first time
and getting excited about it there
should be a slow burn going on
throughout your your life and your
teaching I mean you should be better
educated by the end of your life than
you are at the midpoint in your career
that's not the case unfortunately much
of the time so to bring this to a close
should we make reading Aristotle
compulsory in school yes if if we're
going to have an entire cadre and
cohorts of great educators who can
competently explain and interpret
Aristotle and show students how to apply
it to their own lives we're not going to
do that that the answers
[Music]